hey everybody its Jessie and welcome to
live coding with Jessie today we're
gonna go back to project two and we're
gonna work on that probably just for
today and then we'll go back to the
other project I think we can we can
finish up with what we need to UM
project to today so let me let me just
explain just for a minute what we're
gonna try to do today and then we'll go
through it so SendGrid
is what we've been using to send mail so
I think I I'm pretty sure that I had
some streams at least one stream
dedicated solely to setting up send grid
and sending mail I I was trying to make
the emails a little bit nicer looking so
I was gonna add some introductory text
and before I sent the the form data
through email and I wanted to look up
with the send grid with the same grid
package like what could I do
and as I was looking it up I realized
this was completely different than the
code that I have and so I went back and
looked through the changelog and there
were a ton of breaking changes so many
breaking changes that they actually just
completely changed the name of the
package the NPM package and everything
so we're going to install a new NPM
package that's gonna have the new
SendGrid API I put a link to the github
repo for this in the description for
this video so if you want to read more
about it you can go there at some point
I'll probably be bringing over onto the
screen that you all can see at least
part of the documentation let's see
I think that's pretty much it for for
introduction that that sums up what
we're gonna try to do
let me bring over I had my live chat
kind of buried here hey everybody
okay Sebastian was in here and said he's
submitted a pull request I did see that
but then it looks like he had to go he's
gonna go to dinner all right so anyway
probably later on during the question
answer session I'm gonna go over a few
pull requests there were at least at
least two pull requests that I want to
go over so probably the one that
Sebastian just submitted this not
emerged yet and then we had another one
that I emerged earlier today but I'm
gonna wait and go over those at the
beginning of the question-and-answer
session so probably in about an hour
okay let's get started
so first thing is let's just install
this NPM package so if you're not
familiar with how to install things
let's start our timer if you're not
familiar with how to install things with
NPM this will be a good introduction so
to do this you you need note installed
on your machine and NPM assuming that
you have that set up then this would be
your next step you find so I'm gonna
I'll bring this over to show you you
find your NPM package so this is NPM j/s
calm normally at least for me what it
usually happens is I find what I want to
use on github and then they'll have
instructions to download it on github it
just so happened that the SendGrid the
home page for the SendGrid node client
repo on github doesn't have the
instructions so I had to find it on NPM
so either way you can find the package
on NPM or usually there's github
instructions but anyway you want to look
for something like this and we're using
your
so normally but you know you
most people have npm install it if
they're using node but optionally you
can use yarn they do the same thing so
I'm gonna just copy and paste this so
we're gonna do yarn add to add the
package and this is a new package then
the old name was just send grid so of
wool will remove the the old package
let's paste that in and you see it's
going through and it's installing
everything okay we get warnings warnings
are okay so if you get errors then it
didn't work but warnings are are fine
okay so we had success so you can notice
it actually installs a bunch of
different things that are kind of
separated out we don't really need to
worry about that but it's kind of
interesting to know they do make note of
it in the documentation at some point I
don't remember if it's in here or on
github but we'll go over we don't need
this anymore and let me show you what
happened in our just sit over here so
and our pack is JSON we now have our
send read package with the version
number I so here is our old package
here's our new one and we'll go ahead
and remove this right now I think it's I
think it's yarn remove maybe I'll double
check just to be sure I'm pretty sure
it's you know
yeah okay so we're gonna go yarn remove
SendGrid
okay and now look we can double check
make sure it was removed yep and it's
not here it was there and now it's gone
okay so now we've we've removed the old
version of SendGrid and now we have the
new the new one so let's see we'll check
out our survey j/s file and see what we
need to change now
so obviously we're going to need to
change let's see probably where we're
requiring and how we're requiring this
stuff I would imagine that that changed
so all the I'm gonna have the
documentation up on my other screen and
I'll bring it over if I think you know
maybe there's something that would be
better to see but a lot of this stuff it
would probably be hard to read the
documentation anyway I'd have to make it
really big let's
okay yeah so there is gonna be a little
bit of a difference so let's go with ya
this is gonna be really different now
that I look at it okay so let's just
let's get right into it also if you're
asking questions right now on the live
chat I'm glancing at it occasionally but
after this 25-minute session so my timer
here I'll go back and take five minutes
and answer some questions and then at
the end of the stream I'll answer all
the questions so I don't I don't mean to
give the impression that I'm annoying
the live chat I just have it kind of
partitioned out that I switch back and
forth so I guess if you wanted to follow
along right now I'm just on that
SendGrid NPM page and I'm just checking
out just the very basic use case to you
know
import this and then we'll try to adapt
what we have to match this new this new
way of doing things it's it's really
different I think we'll have to change
pretty much everything from what we did
before and I don't know that I mentioned
this before but the the reason I wanted
to do this and I switched back from
project 3 here not a project to is that
I definitely want people who watch who
are watching this project to know that
there's a new way of doing it since we
already did a stream with the old way I
kind of felt like I I really should show
the newer way because I know there's
some people that follow along with these
projects and they base some of their
projects on that so I almost felt an
obligation to to show the update since
it changed so much
alright so let's bring in oops switch to
my code here let's bring this in so you
know we're changing the names of our
constants so a lots going to have to
change
and when we bring in our API key it's
also different
so I actually not sure that we even want
to do it up here probably down
you know what maybe I'll do it right
here after this is kind of messing up my
organization now but until I think of a
different place to put this here's what
I'm gonna do
you'll see in a second one I'm talking
about so before we actually set the API
key here when we were you know making
this this constant anyway the rainout
like we don't have to that's not the way
it's done anymore so okay cool that's
the the same name so we can just delete
this now let's scroll down to where
we're actually using this so the first
place that we're using anything with
SendGrid
is for that suggest a story form so of
the two forms that we have this one is
by far the simpler of the two so this
will be a good place to start so you can
see right now what we're doing is you
know we're using this helper dot email
and helper dot you know other things to
kind of build up all the elements that
we need and then we're combining them
all here in this mail constant and at
some point we're finally you know
passing this so there's a request let's
see where we actually end up there we go
finally after we combine all of these we
go SJP I and then you know we pass in
the request so it's it's different it's
a lot different now so now I'm gonna
copy and paste over what it's going to
look like I I think this way is actually
it's pretty simple
so we just have one constant now and
we're calling it message and then it's
an object and then we have all the you
know everything that we need right here
that seems a lot more readable to me so
I think that's a good change and then
when we're ready to send that message we
used two s gmail dot send and we pass in
that message so really really easy now
if you notice right there there's no
like error coming through so I need to
look at the documentation you know as we
go go forward to see like shouldn't we
have some error handling so but like I
said the example that I was using right
now was just for like basic how to get
it working so there there is a lot more
in terms of use cases and the
documentation so so this is what I'll be
looking at so there's a lot of use cases
here the URL is more complicated but you
know basically the nodejs SendGrid
that's linked in the description package
is mail use cases MD that's that's how
you get to it if you wanted to follow
along so I'm hoping at some point let's
go to the kitchen sink example here that
way we'll get everything all at once
so let's go through this just so that
you and I both have kind of an idea of
what's possible see I haven't even gone
through this yet I didn't get this far
in the documentation yet all right so
we're good there we're doing all this
you know we have we can do to see this
is good these are things I definitely
wanted to do
this is interesting I've never used
anything with the SendGrid templates
unless sure if I want to look into this
right now for this stream but I'm
interested in that mmm interesting we
can we can add attachments as well we're
gonna have to think about this I didn't
realize that this was possible you know
we already have not for this form but
for the next form that we're gonna work
on you we are getting you know we're
getting files we're sending them but we
weren't sending them in the email now it
will be possible to send these as an
attachment I don't know
I'm asked to think about that that might
not be a bad thing a bad thing to do it
would be almost like another backup
you know already saving them and we're
sending them to project management
system but I mean the email might be
nice as well
okay I see okay I like this I like that
we can use then this is definitely more
in line with what we're doing elsewhere
throughout in survey j/s but really
throughout you know you're using then
we're using a lot of arrow functions so
I like that but this is good this is
what I was hoping that would be in the
the kitchen sink example so let's put
that in now okay so you have this
okay
so let's put in for now let's just copy
and paste all these values probably will
want to change some of these values but
I want something that I can you know
test out right now so we're gonna copy
and paste these and I'm just gonna have
it be sent just to myself right now that
is gonna change but just I can't believe
I just copy and paste at the exact same
email address so that's how it is that
I'm trying to talk and do this at the
same time sometimes I make silly
mistakes okay so now we have text
where's our text email body actually our
email body is HTML so let's put it in
the HTML and that is not a string that
is a variable okay I'm interested to see
if text is necessary I don't think it's
a bad idea to have a text version of the
email let's check out I wonder if it
says anywhere which fields are required
interesting
yeah this template looks this looks
interesting
all right you know it for now I I think
I'm just gonna put in a message let's
see
see
okay and that'll be alright on the off
chance that someone has an email client
that doesn't allow HTML which I've
actually seen it on campus some people
on campus have their email clients set
by default to not show any HTML and only
show the plain text so in case that
happens though at least get a nice
message they won't get all the same data
but they'll get this message and that
should be enough
just to reassure because this would go
to the user and we'll also have one that
goes to our project manager or someone
else in my department I'll probably have
myself bcc'd on everything as well at
least at first to make sure things are
going through properly okay so for now I
wonder I do want to check to see if this
is necessary now or if if we include
HTML then it's just automatic but let's
let's go back to that example that have
everything
yeah I don't see an equivalent feeling
so let's just give it a shot let's get
rid of all of this
let's make sure yeah we want to keep
that bracket but everything else we can
get rid of and we're gonna save that and
what do I have I have this open
somewhere I don't know where now
oh well I'll just open it again so we
have this the the localhost port 9000 is
the one where the forms actually work so
if you're running this locally 3,000
works fine for most things but not for
the forms 9000 is what you want for the
forms I've already went in and I've I've
set my environment variables for sending
emails to true by default everything is
false so that that way if you if you're
kind of playing around with this on your
own on your local machine I don't get
spammed with emails but this should send
the email so you suggest the story
that's interesting okay that's why that
makes sense
I hit enter expecting it to submit but I
was in a multi line input so it's good
that it didn't submit know what happened
all right let's see what the error is
let's see if it comes up here oops it
looks like I forgot a closing friend
well you guys say if it's a singular for
parenthesis is it a paren I've heard
that before but not very often so I'm
not a hundred percent sure on that I
should ask my wife she's an English
professor so she should know things like
that and that was up at the top there we
go it was funny when I when I finished
this the one this earlier I looked at
the end of it and I thought that looks
really weird and then I just kept
scrolling down I didn't take the time to
think about it it's somewhere in my
brain it registered that that was wrong
I suppose okay now let's give it a shot
awesome okay so it says it was
successful and I just got a notification
on my phone and the email says thank you
for your submission actually I want to
see this if if this is visible I've
never tried to show this before on the
screen no it's not it's way too small
but anyway I got the email it came
through so great so that works now now
what we need to do is let's put in some
extra options so this is great right now
but this is not what we want you know
ideally so let's go through and let's do
what what we should do and so what I
mean by that is we need to actually send
two different emails and we can't just
have hard-coded email addresses in here
we need to take the user email we need
to put a proper from email and probably
a from name I'm not that worried about
it for the email that's gonna go to
someone in my department but for the
email that goes to the user I want it to
look you know as professional as
possible right emails that look kind of
shady might not get open it might get
reported as hey I think somebody's like
trying to fish you know or something
like that
so let's we actually did have that
happen before not it wasn't one of my
emails but someone else on the
department was sending out emails and
someone from IT said like hey did you
send this because it looks like you know
it looks kind of shady so now I'm
careful to make sure that my emails look
legit all right so let's add we want to
add a BCC field so let's do that now
I'm gonna BCC me but I don't want my my
personal email let's do my work email
okay so that's good and we want to do
let's take a look at that documentation
again great so here's my check my time
okay I'm almost up so I'm gonna ask a
question and then see what would you all
think it's possible to send two
completely different emails or I could
just send one email and send it to more
than one person or BCC more than one
person or you know anything so do you
think it's better to send two completely
different emails or just have the person
in my department get the email that the
the user would get and just be copied on
it or you know blind copied on it which
would be the simpler option at this
point I at this point there's no reason
to show different data to both of those
people yeah so anyway let me know what
you think that I was thinking I'd like
to send two different emails but now
that I think about it maybe the simpler
approach is better later on I can always
switch it up if I find that I do need to
send different data so let's see okay
cool I already got some answers and it
looks like we're there's at least right
now some agreement on sending you know
just copying on one email yeah after I
kind of said it out loud the answer
became somewhat obvious to me earlier
when I was thinking about it for some
reason I thought that I would need two
different emails all right let me set my
five-minute timer and I'm gonna scroll
up a bit and the live chat and see what
what questions you all have no bears no
beer says what's up how you doing oh not
bad not bad same same stuff same
lack of motivation today but I did
manage on my lunch break to get a lot of
stuff done on my my Redux project so I'm
excited about that because I haven't
worked on it since Saturday and I was
afraid like I'm gonna forget what I was
doing and but I didn't I mean it took me
a while to get my mind back into things
but I was able to work really quickly
and get some tasks out of the way faster
than I even thought that I would be able
to so that was cool hey everybody see
like a lot of people saying hi spar
wheel says can I ask an off topic
question the Q&A yeah definitely yeah
don't worry about it questions are good
you know any any kind of questions are
good I mean coding related questions
obviously you know or are allowed but
even other off-topic questions
I mean if for some reason anybody would
ever ask a question that I did not want
to answer I would just say that so
that's never happened yet but I mean
maybe it could happen so the only
questions I could think of not wanting
to answer would be things that I thought
were like not not like pg-rated stuff
right because we do have like kids watch
this you know we've had how young did we
have I think somebody was 8 years old
watching this at some point we've
definitely had somebody who's 11 but so
anyway those kind of questions would be
the only thing that I could think of
that I wouldn't answer if you ask me
like you know what's the password in my
alarm system on my house I'll probably
want to answer that but anyway that's Oh
Patrick Patrick caught the closing
perennially used parens so that answers
my question so it is paren and thanks
for catching that Patrick it took me
quite a while to realize my mistake hey
Sebastian's back
I wrote one said that Android Oreo
goodness did you notice I'm running Oreo
on my phone so yeah I have the pixel XL
and I'm on Google Phi so I got the Oreo
update like immediately so cool so far I
like it it's not really that different
but the differences are improvements in
my opinion so so far so good on the
Android Oreo update okay so John Hanson
says the singular form is parentheses so
it ends with sis but the plural is
parentheses s es okay that's cool I'm
wondering where that where that endings
from where does the word prevent
parentheses come from is that Latin in
origin or is that Greek in origin if
it's Latin I could probably understand a
little bit more why that's the singular
and plural I'm not really up as much on
my my agent Greek as I am on the Latin
okay so Kade says that I should copy on
a normal email so just do the CC rohan
says BCC yeah oh
you'll see what I'll go with I probably
should ask I needed to check to see
actually on I gotta check the old code
for this and see who I'm sending this to
now because I I think I know who it's
being sent to but I need to double check
so I'll make sure I do that I know where
the the other forum is going for sure
John Hanson says is this server sent
email or will it go through an
authenticated outbound email SMTP it's
it's all being routed so it's not being
sent straight from the server it's being
routed to send grid so I don't I don't
really know what I have set up with and
good to be honest with you I'm not I
don't mess with the email that much to
even know what what different all I know
is that sangra does a good job of
getting the emails where they need to go
right now so I'm sticking with that
let's see root Reuven I think that's how
you'd say that so Reuben says just
joined what's up working on updating the
how we're sending emails through
SendGrid so the send grid node package
got some big updates and breaking
changes and we're going to try to send
well we've just successfully switched
over to it for one of our forms and sent
an email so now we're just going to try
to add some extra things on some extra
options here
okay all right cool so I actually did
get to the bottom of the live chat and
this well I went over the five minutes a
bit but not that much over so I'm gonna
start up another 25-minute session the
way things are going now I think we'll
probably just do one more 25-minute
session because I mean we're gonna get
at least this forum we'll probably get
to the point where it's it's pretty much
finished and then the other forum won't
be you know won't really be different
I'll just copy and paste from this first
forum and it should be about the same I
don't think I'm gonna mess with sending
the files today okay
so let's
hmm okay for now I'm just gonna BCC my
work email because I don't I don't know
for sure who's supposed to be getting
these emails I'll have to look that up
and the current version of this Resource
Center also I don't want to put their
emails right now I guess I could make
them an environment variable so I'll
probably end up doing that but I don't
want to I don't want to look them up
during the stream because that would be
boring
you always see this while I was on my
other screen looking it up so basically
let's just assume that I'm going to add
some extra emails on here now when I do
that I think I need to make them an
array yeah so what I need to do assuming
I'm gonna be CC and not CC I'll just
make an array like that so just in case
you're gonna do something similar that's
how it needs to be done the reply to
let's see
off to think about based on who that
emails going to off to think about the
reply to as well from
I thought somewhere that I had seen
I guess she can't do that anyway
basically like to add something else for
the from not just the email
okay not bad we might just move on to
the other form because I think this is
all we need for this one like I said
this one's really basic form I do want
to check quickly what that email look
like in my browser just to make sure it
looked all right
okay it's not bad it's really really
basic so I'll show you it's it's just
super basic but that's pretty much what
users are getting now it's it's it looks
a little bit better than this but it's
still it's pretty basic okay I'm okay
with that for now
like I said later on I think I want to
look into the templating thing and see I
think it would be a lot easier to set up
a template through SendGrid
than to try to just piece together HTML
and here kind of like what I'm doing now
template literals definitely make it a
lot easier but it would still probably
be better
oh that's why I wondered why I didn't
get two lines there I forgot to close
that tag so anyway template literals
make it a lot easier but I think it
would still be nicer to not clutter up
this already very cluttered server j/s
file with a giant amount of HTML okay
cool so let's let's grab let's see let's
check out our other forum for now see
what we have and then see if we could
just grab most of this and reuse it so
we do have a lot more going on here so
we're doing some checking right we have
to handle files so all this stuff is for
our files and but then at some point we
get to the emails that's down here okay
so it looks like that's the same this is
different
our field string should include at some
point yeah so it does include the the
file names doesn't it no no that's just
the the field still
okay the filenames will be included
already too because because the way we
built the the form so okay so it looks
like I can basically copy and paste
everything we did from up here all we
need to do is change this and this and
it should be fine yeah so let's do that
so far this is easier than than I
anticipated
which is awesome I'm not sure that I oh
no I'm good with this I thought maybe
this was left over
I mean double-check that
okay
No
I'm gonna take all that and I'm gonna
copy it up here and we'll just take this
subject
choose that and then we need field
string
and I'll probably want to do something
like we had done up here so that we're
not just putting in the field string
we'll have some text at the top so let's
get rid of its get rid of all this
and
let's bring in here we go let's bring
this in
Qwest and now we can change this back to
email body
okay
and
no I just let me check I think I have my
environment variables open on my other
screen and okay I don't I thought I had
the project managers email saved already
but I don't but I think that will end up
being the email that's here and maybe
I'll I'll probably double-check as well
to see what the from email is currently
and try to match that okay not bad well
let's test this out make sure we didn't
mess anything up so right off the bat no
errors in the console so that's good and
let's go to our service request form and
I can't remember what fields we ended up
making required
actually before I test this we may as
well try to use the user email for the
two so let's grab it should be we've
made in objects of the fields right okay
so we have this constant fields which is
an object and then we add the fields and
the keys are the names of the field so
I'm pretty sure email is just the the
name of that field so we should be able
to go fields dot email and that'll be
the the users email all right so let's
test that out and it's gonna end up
being the same email okay and I think
yeah I think that was required as well
okay great
do you notice I don't know if you saw
that there's a slight flash at first
when this happens I think what's
happening is we have two different
modal's
so the first modal that pops up says
like sending your process a or something
like that it's basically just you know
loader then then it comes up with done
but there's a slight flash when it when
it happens really fast so I think what
I'll probably end up doing is make it so
that two different modal's don't appear
but that the text inside the modal
changes that way that'll just be one
modal we shouldn't get the flash or at
least it shouldn't be
as big of a flash because instead of the
entire modal changing it will just be
the text inside
okay so let me check and check my email
okay just got the email great okay so it
came through
that's gonna need cleaned up a bit so
let me show you what it looks like this
one definitely needs cleaned up more so
I don't really want to use her seeing
all this so I think it would be better
if and now I just realized that why are
they
I thought that I had put in oh you know
what I had I had put in the right ones
let me see okay I just didn't build yet
so anyway alright so that should be
better but it's still gonna be I don't
want them to see all these falses so
we'll have to make it so that if it is
false it doesn't get sent with the email
because that's that's not really great
to see also I don't like the order of
these I think it would be better if it
was in a different order so I need to
clean that up a little bit again though
I'd like to check out what can be done
with templates from but I'm probably
it's somewhere in the SendGrid dashboard
that I'll be creating the templates but
the cool thing is it did grab the users
email which in this case was me and it
sent it to the correct email so that's
what we wanted so I want to take that
sip what we did there and I mean not
really that much I guess I didn't really
have to copy copy it but we're gonna put
that up here oops
I'm gonna save that and I mean actually
I don't know that there's that much more
that really needs done you know other
than the few things that I said we would
maybe do let me check the timer and see
how much time we have left all right ten
minutes
[Music]
let's see
sorry oh she's checking the live chat
quickly but yeah I kind of think I I'm
not gonna try to add a new feature you
know within ten minutes I don't think I
can the next thing that I would probably
want to do is check out those templates
and see if that would be an easy
solution to clean this up a little bit
make it look nicer but there's no way
that I can get that done in ten minutes
so I think what we'll end up doing is
I'm gonna go now take the rest of this
time to go over the pool request we've
got so you know anytime any of you
submit a pull request I definitely want
to give you credit for it and bring
everybody up to date on you know any
changes in the project so I'm gonna do
that and then we'll do our question
answer to finish out so if you have
questions now please put them in the
live chat and as I said earlier don't
you know know almost no question is
really off topic here so don't worry
about you know whether or not your
question is relevant
any questions are fine with me let's see
you bring over
all right so we did just get a pull
request so I am going to open that up if
then I'm also going to show you this
lady's pull request that I just merged
okay and actually I don't think I ever
talked about this one to the last two I
don't think I talked about all right so
these two are related so so we've had so
cuckoo Kieran
it's that has added I mean I was reading
this to double check make sure I get it
right
okay so added the link so we had a
readme for people who want to contribute
to the project but they're really new
they don't understand get so Sebastian
had opened an issue and suggested that
we put in information about how to use
git and github so we had some
information in there but now we have a
lot so with these two pull requests they
have a lot of info so I added some
suggestions Sebastian added some
suggestions so between the three of us
we've got quite a few resources so I can
show you now we have a lot of good
resources for beginners on you know how
to fork the project and just general get
help so I know I have done this course
that was good and I did this course on
Udacity as well so I personally can
recommend those two courses the Udacity
course was I found was really thorough
and it had some other beneficial things
like teaching you how to get different
colors and you're in your command line
which not necessary but kind of cool so
anyway so thanks for that and if there's
anybody that's kind of new to get you
know check that out and you know if you
go through some of these you definitely
you know what's going on when it comes
to get and
and this other pull request we just got
right before I started this dream so I
wanted to go over this and talk about
this because I think there's a really
good observation about the UI and a good
pool request but I did want to ask you
out what you thought so I really like
the idea but I think I want to implement
it in a slightly different way so let me
show you what what I'm talking about
I'll go to this one so on the logos so
right now there's no indication of where
where we're at I guess I should have
went to this one so that we could
actually see the logos so anyway there's
no indication of which one you're you're
on currently and you know Sebastian saw
this and said yeah we definitely need
that and I completely agree so Sebastian
I think it just changed the font weight
of it which definitely works and I'll
I'll probably just pull that in and use
that but at some point I think what I'd
like to do is make these change how
these are right now and make them tabs
like material design tabs I don't know
why I didn't do that right off the bat
but I think the way this is you know
currently I think it really makes sense
to be tabs you know we have it one
across the top here and let me show you
what I mean by tabs I'm gonna go on
materialized normally I go right to the
documentation for material design
Google's documentation but this way I
think will be a little bit more
interactive we can see with the with the
tabs are here JavaScript
yeah tabs okay so you can see like the
tabs
we'll go across the top and basically
the indicator would be this little
underlined let me see if they have any
other example so the indicator would be
a little underlined and then it would
you know flip around you know based on
that so I'm thinking that would be the
best way to go now we aren't we aren't
using materialized for the tabs right
we're using material UI so I probably
should check the terior UI and see how
how its implemented there okay so here
we go same same thing you click the tag
or the tab and you get the underline so
that's what I'm thinking that will end
up will end up doing that I'm not I'm
not really worried about it but since
we're going with the material design
thing I think that would be the more
consistent way to handle that I'm trying
to find it again I keep flipping around
everywhere so I think that would be a
more consistent way to handle that to
use the tabs and then we would still
though once it got small go to something
like this so the the only thing that I'm
you know kind of slightly not sure about
is I vaguely remember something about
the tabs like you shouldn't have a
million tabs with material design so
this is quite a lot of tabs so I don't
know so that might be I'm not I'm not
worried about going against material
design specs if we need to for this use
case and I think it would be fine I
think it'd be okay to drop drop down to
this like we have here which oh man I
never fixed that
maybe did I fix it I did I just okay so
this this version is a bit out of date
so I did fix it I thought I fixed it
okay so anyway that's the that's the
pool request so thank you Sebastian
like I said I'll probably pull that in
because I think it's important to have
but longer-term I'm thinking that maybe
I would want to change that to tabs so I
don't know if anybody really wants to
try that out you know feel free that
would be awesome I don't know how soon
I'll get to it I don't think that's
something that I really need before we
launch so I'd really rather work on
project three as much as I possibly can
because then I have to switch projects
again in October I just kind of want to
get this one done and launch it and then
I can always come back and change things
when I get a chance later on alright so
that's that's the end of that
FOMA Torres session so it's good timing
and now I will go back to the live chat
and I'm gonna answer all the questions
in the live chat unless for some reason
we get lots and lots of questions but
should be able to get to everything it
doesn't look to look like there's too
many questions right now so if you if
you can't stick around for the
question/answer session then thanks for
watching and I'll be back tomorrow so
hopefully you can come back and catch
the live stream again but if you have a
few extra minutes and can stick around
even if you don't have a question I'd
really appreciate if you could help
answer questions in the live chat your
expertise is definitely a big benefit to
everybody I think that that watches the
stream and to me as well so let me find
where
stuff
okay so here's a good comment
so Rohan is talking about emails and
said I tried setting up my own email as
experiment and says it looks so simple
in theory but with modern add-ons you
will miss something it's better to just
use something like SendGrid
i mean that's basically what i the
conclusion that I came to as well and
why I was using SendGrid
initially I had so there were several
reasons that went into my choice for
SendGrid but that was one of the reasons
so I won't say that it's the only reason
I used it but yeah but that's definitely
you know if you really want to get into
you know how to send emails and things
is something you're interested in then I
it would certainly be you know
beneficial to you to try to do it you
know from scratch on your own but if
that's not something that really
interests you then you know using
something like SendGrid is the best way
to go in my opinion John Hanson says so
jonad asked earlier about what I was
using so if it was a server if the email
sent from the server is SMTP I think I
got that right that I mix up that
acronym yeah SMTP that's right so John
says that's a prayer type answer to the
email sending protocol I've used PHP
mailer and even then I was shocked at
how controlled email security and spam
detection effects form submitted email
yeah I I said I I haven't had any issues
with SendGrid so far so we've been using
it for a year over a year with this so I
think in this particular case I'll be
I'll be fine if the audience wasn't in
turn
so I mean right now I know the audience
and I know what has words if the
audience was external I might put a lot
more thought into and do more testing
for this John Hanson also said if
SendGrid has some type of nicely
formatted email template I'd go for that
too yeah I think I mean I want to check
it out and see see how easy it is to use
and what it looks like but I mean right
now my emails look pretty basic so it
would be it would be nice if they look
better Sebastian says tabs are a good
idea so on this logo page but how will
they work on small screens okay
Sebastian I'm sorry I didn't so
Sebastian says there's a bit more to the
pool request and I just I didn't check
it out so I'm sorry I didn't check this
pull request like I said it came in
right before the stream started so I'm
sorry Sebastian so let's see point two
oh okay so I mean obviously you all can
read but in case somebody's just
listening and can't see the and it's not
actually looking at the video Sebastian
also removed the the a tags that were
inside the allies for all the the tabs
that we have now basically what it was
doing because they were a tags it was
changing the hash in the URL and you're
saying that's kind of annoying also
unnecessary it's not like we're grabbing
that and doing anything with it like
automatically bringing you to that
category so I agree that that was
definitely a good move so now there's no
a tags it's just a lies you know the
Allies are the ones that have the the on
click handler anyway so
yeah so sorry I missed that again and
thank you for that
okay so che asks what are some other
favorite design guides / languages
besides material design trying to think
what is so Microsoft has their design
what do they call it
I cannot remember what Microsoft's
they're basically their latest design
thing is what they use for like office
365 and I'm sorry I can't remember so
like basically Microsoft has their
version of design Sebastian says fluent
or something that yeah I can't I can't
remember
and then Apple has their version so with
iOS what do they call it now I can't
remember I just I just heard this I was
just watching a video earlier on react
native and and they mentioned in the
video what the name of the design is for
iOS Wow I I'm doing a terrible job
answering this question so although I
can't remember the names of it okay cool
so chases Microsoft is fluent so Apple
Google and Microsoft all have their own
distinct design languages fluent for
Microsoft interior design for Google and
something that I can't remember for for
[ __ ] now that's it okay human I knew
it was interface something so Apple is
called human interface Thank You Shea
okay so in terms of like your big tech
companies those are your design things
but then there's also like I mean
there's bootstrap right so bootstrap is
I don't think it when you think of
design if it would come up that like all
bootstraps are design philosophy like in
the same way that material design is but
if you look at the web bootstrap is
influenced design a lot right you can
you can't always tell if someone use
bootstrap because you can certainly cost
a lot and it won't look like bootstrap
but there are a lot of sites out there
that are just basic bootstrap you go to
the site and you don't even have to
check you know they use bootstrap for
that all right it's just used so so many
places so just for the influence alone I
would definitely say that it's it should
be lumped in with some of the big design
things now there was so there is design
that it's falling out of favor now but I
think it's called skeuomorphic design
it's spelled really it's like sk ii you
mor ph i see something like that so but
it's um from what i understand at least
and i'm not i don't think i'm at all an
expert in design but from what I
understand it was more like you take
like real-world things and have them in
the design so I guess an example would
be I don't know if anybody remembers the
old music player for windows that when
amp and you can get different skins for
when amp and some of them actually
looked like a stereo like a real-life
stereo with buttons you know and
switches and stuff and you could press
them like I said from my understanding
of skeuomorphic design that would be an
example that the interface actually
looks like what the equivalent thing
would look like in real life so someone
please correct me if I'm getting that
wrong but I think that's it so I also
Sebastian mentions foundation so
foundation is basically does the same
thing as bootstrap and that's also
that's also been influential so I don't
know the statistics offhand I'm pretty
sure that bootstrap is used on more
sites right now but I hear a lot of good
things about foundation I've looked
through through their Docs
remember if I ever used it on a project
certainly not on any you know projects
for clients or anything I may have used
it just on some some side projects
though okay so anyway Shay I hope I
answered your question somewhat sorry I
can't like I said I'm just not I'm not
that well-versed and all the different
you know design philosophies for for web
design okay good so Shay says you're
right about secure morphic Apple was
also really into it for a while think
the notes up yeah actually I was I was
thinking that too the Notes app is a
great example because it looks like a
actual piece of paper like notepad paper
so yeah I'm actually um I think ASCII
morphic design is interesting and cool
to look at sometimes but I'm I'm not a
fan of it for actual like ease of use so
I'm kind of glad that we got away from
that I think for its I don't know my
view on website design is like the sites
that win like the design awards so what
is it like the aaww I can't remember
what it what the website is called but
the sites that we design awards aren't
always the most user-friendly sites
sometimes you go to these sites and you
have no idea how to navigate or what's
going on but it looks really cool so I
to me scheme Orphic design fits more
into that category in terms of sometimes
it can look really cool but it's not
necessarily the most user-friendly right
like to go back to the old winamp
example I'm pretty sure like there were
some elements in the UI of some of those
skins that looks cool and it looked like
a real stereo or something but it didn't
actually do anything when you clicked it
right so there there are elements like
that now could you do it so that that
didn't happen I'm sure you could
but then would it look less realistic I
don't know
so now on the other side of things I
think like material design is probably
not gonna win any Design Awards like you
you're I don't know that I've ever seen
a sight when a design award and I'm
talking about let me just bring the site
up so that we all know we're talking
about also let me know if there's
anybody mine that I have the live set up
on the screen because I mean I guess
your name would be on on the video I
know I already say your names but let me
know I just brought it over to this
screen because this screen has the
camera on it right now
and I just wanted to be kind of looking
more at the camera instead of to the
side so let me bring this up there we go
yeah aw it's a few words so let me show
I was trying to go to the home page we
can see so this is what I'm talking
about I'm talking about awards is mostly
this is what I go to to see like you
know whit's which sites so I'm sure
there are other other awards but this
tends to have like some really out there
designs and things so like I said so I
don't think you're ever gonna find just
a straight-up by-the-book material
design site on here but a material
design site seems to be really user
friendly so so my take on on design it's
somewhat just depends on what you're
going for with that that particular site
and it would depend I mean if it's for a
client you know if your clients a
fashion designer I think you could get
away with doing something that's really
more like artistic even if it's less
user friendly because the goal of a site
like that might not be like hey we want
a bunch of users here to be able to do
something in particular the goal is we
want to make an impression we make an
impact right so it just it just depends
you know on what you're going for and
sometimes it's hard to keep that in mind
I know like with project one which was
the catechetical Institute website it
was definitely a struggle there were
some people involved in the project that
I think they had in their minds that
they really wanted this to make an
impact they wanted it to be like
visually stunning which is awesome but
you know I just kept asking well like
what is the point of this site what do
you want people to do what do you know
what do you want to get from this site
so eventually I think we've reached a
nice compromise where we had some
elements that were there that were
somewhat striking you know visually but
we were able to work in a lot of very
functional things so I you know that's I
think it's kind of it's always a
struggle depending on who you're working
with as to where you go you know in
terms of design let's see if some more
things okay John Hanson says flat design
started in 2012 not so long ago so yeah
yeah there's definitely forgotten about
that but there's the the flat design oh
cool so Sebastian likes to chat on the
screen awesome let me let me scroll up a
bit because I think I skipped over some
things
okay so let me go said dead zombie says
I just got into front-end development
and I'm trying to learn a responsive
design is bootstrap a good starting
point or what's your opinion where
should I start from let's see yeah I
mean bootstrap is bootstrap is good I
guess it it kind of depends too on what
you what you want to do like if you I
guess you're saying front end it's a
friend development sponsor design yeah
so I would say you can focus a lot on
CSS and get really good at making these
custom layouts and things or there's a
lot of people to focus on javascript and
they do a lot with javascript and don't
worry so much about the customs layouts
and they're happy to just use some
pre-made system I've that's kind of
where I'm at
I do enjoy customizing things with CSS
but I I rely you know I kind of fall
back on either materialized or material
UI you know so and I fall back on the
material design guidelines so I guess
it's kind of what you want if your goal
is to be able to like make things from
scratch in CSS and get really good at
CSS then maybe you don't want to use
bootstrap right away if your goal is
just to start making websites and you
know build up and get better with
JavaScript and yeah definitely use
bootstrap because it's going to take
care of a lot of little detail things
that could slow you up and would be
unnecessary if you're not really trying
to get your deep into CSS
so I mean there's no I I don't think
there's any problem at all with was
starting out using bootstrap so even
like in the free code camp courses or
you know there exercises it starts out I
mean you do some basic CSS but it really
starts out with bootstrap and and allows
you to use bootstrap for some of those
projects so I think it's a good way to
just move forward and get some
confidence using sites and and then even
beyond that you know if that works and
you're making sites you're making good
sites that people can use and get things
done and your clients are happy with I
don't really see a problem in using
bootstrap and and never going on
anything else if that's not really what
you're into
and then again as well you don't have to
go with bootstrap certainly you could go
with foundation you could go with
materialized you could go with trying to
things with some of the other one there
are some that are lighter lighter
frameworks so you don't want it's not
like you have to go with a framework or
nothing you can kind of go in between so
there's some really lightweight
frameworks that just will give you like
you know some bare-bones things maybe
like some column classes and and then
you take care of a lot of the rest so
you could compromise with that so that a
lot of them or I don't know kind of
mundane things are taken care of and
then you add on top of that some of the
more like creative visual elements so
anyway so I mean I know you have a lot
of choices sometimes it makes it harder
to choose with more choices but you know
at first like choose a system that you
like how it looks because you want to
like what you're building so if you
really like how bootstrap looks then go
with that otherwise you know find
something that you really like Sebastian
says I used to love when amp old times
yeah for sure
when F was awesome back in the day with
all the custom skins you can have those
those really cool
gah
Nitish says I I feel front end is hard
but I enjoy developing back-end stuff
what should I learn to become a decent
web developer if you like back-end stuff
and you want to learn some front-end so
essentially like you're gonna be in full
static right so if you like that the
idea of being able to do everything and
you like back-end now when you go into
front-end I recommend like using things
like a CSS framework like we just talked
about bootstrap materialized foundation
something like that or even something
like react with material UI so that a
lot of the HTML CSS stuff is taken care
of for you you can you know learn some
JavaScript so that you can make things
work but you know realistically when
you're dealing with something like react
and if you use a component library
you're not writing very much HTML at all
or CSS instead you're thinking about the
logic of it of state management and
things like that which I think may be
easier to go into because you know
you're still using a programming
language instead of like HTML or CSS so
that might be a way to build out things
on the front-end without having to worry
too much about design and and
essentially you you would be able to
build complete complete apps you know
front and back so if at some point it
starts to get easier for you and you
find you like it you can dig deeper in
the front-end but until then you know I
would I definitely recommend going with
something that's that's built out as
much as possible already like so
something like you know create react app
with a UI frame
work you know already there and you just
put the pieces together pop in some data
you have an app right you won't be able
to customise it too much if you don't
really want to get into that but at
least you'll have something that's
functional
I think that's important once you have
some function you can always mess with
it and you know adapt it as your skills
get better
see
okay so in response to what we were
talking about earlier two dead zombies
question the dead zombie says never try
to framework before use a lot of custom
CSS for my school projects also yeah I'm
learning through a free code cam thanks
for your opinion you're welcome
no problem hopefully it's helpful to you
okay so so GS nity says well if I want
to be a just a back-end guy what should
I start with which would be easier if
I'm completely new to web dev okay so
you're saying you want to be in web
development but you're not worried about
front-end now what if you just wanted to
do back in I don't know I mean I'm
probably not the best person to answer
this question because I am I'm more of a
front-end person but in terms of
back-end like you know date just the
basics of databases you know either
you know sequel or no sequel it doesn't
really matter you know learn how to
interact with a database
build api's so I would I mean for sure
you REST API is right everybody uses
those but I would even check out
something like graph QL that seems to be
like the new thing that in my opinion
graph QL seems superior to REST API and
I'm I'm excited for the day whenever you
know most of the REST API czar instead
graph QL API but yeah I would so I think
what other back-end things yeah I mean I
would definitely at least learn some
JavaScript so it's not going to be as
foreign to you as HTML and CSS would be
you don't need to go full-on JavaScript
if you're just gonna stick with back-end
but you know that would help bridge the
gap a bit so you can understand like
what you know some of what's going on
client side and then if you wanted to
handle some things in nodejs on the
backend you know you could you could
pick that up but you know PHP is still
really popular back and language for for
the web so I mean you have things like
WordPress which is built in PHP Drupal
you know those are your big PHP ones
what else I'm pretty sure Jun loves PHP
C I mean you have those and then you
also have the whole realm of like you
know dotnet stuff right so if you're
familiar with C++ it might not be that
big of a jump to get into c-sharp you
know get into some dotnet framework
things so any I mean you have a lot of
options really at this point I think
your best bet would be to read up on
some of your different language options
so for back-end you know php.net
framework nodejs read them up on them
maybe do some like basic tutorial things
on them just to get a feel for it and
then you know if you have up at that
point if you really like one over the
other then go for that my other advice
in this kind of thing is always if you
have a certain company you would love to
work for or a few companies find out
what stack they use and learn that right
because if you have no idea how to use
their stack or whatever language they're
using the odds of you getting a job
there are probably pretty low so if you
let's say you don't really care what
language you use but you do care about
you know where you work then that's
another you know another way to go about
it anyway hopefully that that helps you
out a little bit it can be really tough
at the beginning when you're when you're
trying to figure out what do I learn
once you start to get an idea for what
you really like and can start to
specialize I think that's when it gets
really fun it's tough because once you
specialize in one thing you're saying no
to everything else but then you start to
really feel like you know what you're
doing and that you're building cool
things at least that's been my
experience
okay Sebastian says I have Windows 10
with their fluent design and as many
things borrowed from material design
yeah I agree I don't use Windows 10
often but I have been checking out
office 365 so recently well I get within
the last year I was on a committee to
choose between switching over or my
university to office 365 or G suite so
we had to test out both systems and I
thought the same thing I thought that
Microsoft designed definitely at times
felt a little bit like material design
which was cool I
they said I really think diversity of
design is great for making really
awesome things that look nice but
uniformity is great for user experience
so I'm not against it
John Henson says bootstrap is a great
way to understand the first steps into
the whole NPM and node setup and using
an editor the documentation is amazing
for it - no beer recommends even if you
want to just be a back-end developer you
should probably know a little bit of
HTML CSS and JavaScript so yeah yeah I
mean that's I think that's good advice
and really HTML and CSS are not they're
not that hard to learn and I always shy
away from saying oh it's easy because
everything seems easy once you've been
doing it for years right but in this
case I really do believe that in terms
of every you know the the entire
computer science realm right if we want
to talk about which things are hard to
learn which things are easy HTML CSS are
definitely on the easy side of things to
learn so if you've been able to
comprehend other concepts like in C++
and Java if you just took some time and
really worked on CSS and HTML just to
get some basic understanding I think
you'll be fine
john hanson still has winamp installed
and uses it that's awesome I didn't even
realize when amp was like still still a
thing that's really cool yeah I actually
I use Spotify all the time now so I
don't have any like any player any media
player that I use other than that
let's see Sumanth s kindly suggest me a
few important interview questions where
node is used as a back end hmm
so basically what questions should a
back-end developer prepare for would be
my question I don't really know that I
that I would know that especially if you
wanted to be a back-end developer I mean
I guess if you wanted to be a front-end
developer and they just wanted to know
like do you know some basic stuff I
don't know maybe I'd be more helpful
there yeah I don't know I don't want to
try to guess and give you silly
questions so I'm not going to pretend
like I'm qualified for that but I will
say there are definitely some resources
out there so I mean I don't want to just
give you the answer you would but really
recently I was involved in an interview
process for a web developer and I
googled a lot of questions to ask during
the interviews and there's there's a lot
out there a lot of good stuff out there
so I don't think it'll be very hard for
you to find some questions should I
think Stack Overflow jobs I think has
some resources where they they have on
their blog or something like that they
have interview questions for different
types of developers so I would check
there I know there are lists on github
of interview questions just off the top
of my head those are two resources that
that I had used and and we actually took
some of those questions and use them for
the for the interviews
that zombie says yeah I love watching
your streams awesome I appreciate that
let me say I just got a slack message I
want to check and make sure it's nothing
I need to handle right now all right
yeah nothing it's I don't know about you
all but it for me for my department
slack is I would say like I don't know
70% used maybe 75% used for just kind of
casual talking and joking and 25% for
actual work-related stuff so but I still
like to check if I get something that
might be important
let's see Mandela effect conference ass
is laravel good or not
honestly I I have no knowledge at all of
laravel so hopefully somebody in the
live chat knows let's see
Oh actually shinobi er says larva is a
popular one and a powerful one of the
PHP frameworks nowadays that's it okay
now that you say that I did know that it
was associated with PHP so but that's
about the extent of my knowledge no beer
asked what's the software you're using
for live video on YouTube Sebastian said
OBS yeah it's it's OBS so actually oh
man I'm sorry I forgot I just put this
on the screen and it's probably like
yeah it is I can't believe I didn't
notice that let me flip this over I just
wanted to make sure that the camera was
like basically centered on me I was
worried I was out of the frame so anyway
sorry about that
GS the T says what what is dotnet and if
it how is it different from no jazz okay
so I'm just going to read off some of
the answers to that because I think
there's already some good answers in
here Mandela effect conference says
dotnet asp.net c-sharp are all Microsoft
stuff access there's a bootcamp in Ohio
for c-sharp yes so GSN to teach I have
select my last two streams any of my
streams that are from like it says
Project three I'm using dotnet stuff so
basically it's just another kind of way
of building backends for for a website
so I don't know if you're familiar at
all with WordPress but WordPress uses
PHP to put together little snippets of
HTML and make these basically templates
for pages that grab the data from a
database insert it into these templates
put it all together and then send to the
client to the you know to the browser
from the server HTML right so with
dotnet you're using c-sharp and asp.net
to do the same thing to piece together
pieces of HTML that then get populated
with data from a database right so it's
that's all it does right and so it I
guess it's just what it comes down to
they all do the same thing right so most
of your your back in web languages we're
doing to do the same thing right it's
it's all just piecing together HTML and
combining it with data so it's just a
matter of what language do you like like
I said what language do you like working
with or what language does the company
use that you really want to work
Blake asks what is the general consensus
on Ruby Ruby on Rails I don't know I've
never used it from what I've heard
though I've heard it's it's simply
simple to learn and use but I can't
verify that personally that's just what
what I've heard from articles people on
YouTube
akshay says where can we get the
Microsoft patches for Windows 10.1 I
don't really know like I said so I don't
hopefully somebody in the live chat can
give a better answer here but I don't
like I said I rarely use Windows 10 so
I'm not really up on when the when the
updates are coming out
okay so rich Rishabh says I work as
full-stack developer with meteor and
react native oh that's cool
I've seen some demos with meteor and it
seems it seems really cool I want to
learn more about it
shroo John says hi I have created my own
portfolio website on github pages using
bootstrap and there's some Python a
JavaScript I wish to make augmented
reality apps that's really cool that's
that's cool too I think that's a really
cool area to get into you know cuz it's
just it's so new it's awesome to be part
of something that's new and changing so
fast but true John asks what can I learn
next I don't really know I mean with
augmented reality like I'm I'm not sure
it seems these days there's a way to do
everything with JavaScript so I'm sure
she'd learn more JavaScript there's
probably some library out there that
lets you do augmented reality with it I
just am not familiar with it right now
other than that I don't really know does
anyone know what's what's the commonly
used thing for augmented reality right
now I'm just I really haven't even
checked into it so sorry I can't be more
more more help to you I'm just not
really I think it's really cool what I'm
excited about more augmented reality
stuff but I don't really have very much
knowledge about what's being used right
now for it okay Umberto's says Visual
Studio has hololens development stuff if
you don't like mine learning dotnet okay
cool
that that makes sense you know hololens
being Microsoft's products
see sumon says you are so wonderful that
you take time to read everyone's
comments I'm watching all your live
streams just for this Oh awesome that's
cool I appreciate that
sometimes I worry because occasionally I
get comments from people that say like
you talk too much and they I mean that's
that's fine I I don't deny that I talk a
lot
sometimes I go off on tangents but
sometimes I wonder like should should I
have more coding and not do so much
question answer stuff at the end but
it's good to know that that you like the
question-and-answer stuff so that's what
I think I think there's a few unique
things about this stream and one of the
unique things I think is the the live
chat the interaction the
question-and-answer stuff I mean I'm not
saying the only person that does it
certainly I haven't watched everybody
else's streams to know but I I think
it's kind of a cool feature
okay Umberto also says Google has a our
core for augmented reality iPhone has a
art kit okay cool
this is cool info okay and Umberto's
said that he did just hear about a
javascript framework for AR meaning
augmented reality but can't remember
what it is okay cool I mean there's like
I said there's got to be something for
jobs I just read an article yesterday
about doing machine learning with
JavaScript it was actually like a mess
in the comments though there are people
saying you definitely shouldn't do it
something about the way that math is
done in JavaScript but anyway I had to
quit reading it because I was realized
like hey this has nothing to do with
anything I'm working on so it's probably
a waste but anyway it does just seems
like you can do everything in JavaScript
these days oh cool Americo says a rjs
that makes sense and that's easy to
remember awesome on bears up
Oh shrew John says Google's a our core
is limited to only pixels and si oh wow
that's cool so I have a pixel maybe I
should check it out since I can since I
can develop with that no beer says yeah
you talk too much but I like it ha ha
all right that's cool I'm one of those
people that I'm really quiet at first
but once I get started up I talk a lot
alright there sometimes I'm in meetings
and I say nothing like literally
literally I was in a meeting a few days
ago and one of my bosses said are you
gonna say anything at the end and I just
shook my head I had enough I felt like I
had nothing valuable to add to the
conversation so I just I wasn't going to
talk but anyway
okay so Regan asks is it possible to
learn to only learn a JavaScript library
without learning JavaScript itself I
would I would give it a qualified yes
and the qualification would be you would
certainly have to learn some JavaScript
to be able to use the library you could
probably get away with only learning a
certain amount of JavaScript and not
let's say mastering everything and then
as to whether or not that's advisable I
don't I don't know I mean you could
probably build some things like that but
at some point you would if you want to
get better and be able to really
customize and do things with that
framework outside just the very normal
scope of it you probably wouldn't want
to learn more JavaScript so I don't know
hopefully that's an okay answer dead
zombie says considering that javascript
library is based on JavaScript I think
you do need to learn JavaScript before
you try learning libraries yeah yeah so
yeah I think I'm kind of the same way
right like if I were to if you were to
ask me what I thought was the best way
to learn everything then I would say
yeah try to learn JavaScript and then
get into a library instead of the other
way around but if the question is is it
possible to learn a library without
learning JavaScript yeah yeah and and by
not learning JavaScript I mean not
learning a lot of JavaScript you
definitely do need some Blake says I
like the comments I'm the same way
not talking talking cool
cool you understand Mandela effect
conference says start with HTML CSS
jQuery then go to vanilla JavaScript
yeah actually that's a common thing
really now that I think about it so I
guess if you want to talk about you know
is a JavaScript library a lot of people
who do start with jQuery and it helps
them to you know manipulate the Dom and
do some cool things without getting into
the JavaScript so I'm not sure how I
feel about that that's how I started out
but it's it's hard to switch it it is
really hard to force yourself to learn
how to do it in vanilla JavaScript
because the jQuery Way is often so much
easier so I don't know I mean jQuery
allowed me to get a lot of cool stuff
done and you know make money building
websites so I don't I don't regret that
but I do think I probably would have
gotten better at JavaScript faster if I
had forced myself not to use it but I
wasn't really in a position to be picky
about things you know I had I had to pay
the bills I had to feed my kids and I
had to take on clients that needed work
done so I mean I just I need to get it
done and jQuery can certainly help you
do that but if you did have the luxury
of being able to you know try to learn
things exactly in the way you want to
you know however you want to learn them
then I don't know that I would have done
jQuery first
okay
I'm pretty sure I got all the questions
in I'm just gonna glance quickly here at
the end of the live chat
okay Umberto had a useful comment here
in terms of us we're talking about
Google's AR core only working with with
a limited amount of funds here
Umberto's says they are working on
making it available for all their
devices it'll just be a more lightweight
version since they won't necessarily
have the optimized hardware okay cool
that's good to know yeah I really want
to get into some of that stuff augmented
reality stuff seems really cool maybe I
can find some way to get into it as a
project for work that would be pretty
awesome otherwise I don't know that I'll
have that much time as a side project
but okay Blake said did you talk about
the Ruby on Rails I didn't catch that
yeah you know what
I remember saying something about it but
I don't think we I went on to read
anything else about Ruby on Rails I
think the only thing I said about it was
that I thought it was supposed to be
pretty simple to pick up and learn how
to use
okay and now I can trying to look back
up in the chat for things on Ruby on
Rails so I'm not seeing anything right
now
okay Mandela effect conference did say
something similar to Ruby on Rails might
be a PHP framework Ruby language I don't
know what is similar that is actually
used crystal language is similar to Ruby
but is not used okay so I think that's
all I found on Ruby as far as I know
Ruby on Rails was like gained a lot of
profit popularity out only years ago I
don't remember about how many years ago
but it seems like it's lost some
popularity right around the same time
that nodejs is kind of gained popularity
oh that's just my observation I don't
really have numbers you know on hand to
back that up but I just don't hear rails
talked about quite as much as I used to
okay
okay sorry so Blake repeated said that
said my question was what is the general
consensus on Ruby on Rails okay all
right so I mean what I just said
basically is pretty much my opinion on
Rails just like you can certainly still
use rails to build stuff it works and
people still use it but if you had to
ask me like if if you want to position
yourself to have great like job skills
that are in demand it just does seem
like it seems like it's just losing
popularity right so PHP to be honest
with you because of how popular
WordPress is I think PHP is still really
valid to know node has really grown and
continues to grow especially like with
Reax popularity you know a lot of reacts
although you don't necessarily need node
need to use known as a back-end it seems
like a lot of the time node is the back
end so for me at least I'm focusing on
learning more node stuff for back-end I
learned the I use other stuff when I
have to for like a legacy project but I
don't know that I would recommend unless
someone had a really good reason for
wanting to learn rails I don't know that
I would recommend it as you know being
like the best career move that they
could make
but once again I'm gonna say like if you
happen to really like it
go with it if you know the company
really like uses it go with it but just
in general I don't know that I would
recommend it but I never used it so take
that into consideration with my answer
as well let's see Reagan asked between
PHP and Python which language is the
best for you know bear says PHP is best
I think it depends on what you want to
do if you're talking about web
development deal with PHP if you're
talking about machine learning go with
Python data science I will go with
Python and that's just based on what the
most popular languages are for those
things I've rarely ever hear of people
using Python in regard to web
development but PHP is all over the
place and even things like like all your
shared hosting environments you know are
running PHP stuff all the time it seems
like I don't know that I've ever tried
to run Python on them so maybe they run
Python - I don't I just don't know but I
do know at least right now from what
I've read for things like data science
and machine learning Python is the the
number one language being used
Mandela effect conference says rails is
on the decline in the US Europe and US
says Europe and Australia might be
better but not sure okay so that seems
to be the consensus that rails are still
used but it is you know declining at
least in the u.s. okay
rich rich Hobbs says is is happy jsh api
je s better a better alternative to
meteor for rest services
I don't really know I've I probably know
more about meteor than I know about
happy so but but really it's it's very
limited it's limited to seeing other
people do stuff with it so I don't know
that I can really answer that so sorry I
just don't have enough experience with
it to give you a good answer
Bert Burke so BER ke so sorry if I'm
pronouncing that wrong let me know if
I'm if I am I'll pronounce it right
so Berg says hi when when is react going
to be available in free code camp I
don't know
so it seems like the the answer that
Quincy always gives is soon basically
the answer is when it's when we're
confident that it's ready it will be it
will be released and I actually don't
have anything to do with developing that
so I really I don't have any more
information than you all have with that
so there are a lot of other people
volunteering to to make that work and it
github so you can check check out github
and just see like how many pull requests
are there in bugs and things and if you
really you know kind of want to dig
deeper and find out where you know where
that projects at or even help I'm sure
that would it would appreciate any help
that you could give
see
timo says I personally feel like it will
take a while before the beta which will
include react is ready yeah honestly I
have no idea it's been a long time since
I even checked out the beta I know it's
been a long time in development but I
don't know it's still hard to me like I
said I'm not involved in it but I would
imagine it's got to be hard to try to
come up with a curriculum for web
development because it changes so fast
you know if you take too long to develop
it the stuff you did at the beginning is
probably already outdated so that's I
mean that's a challenging thing so I
mean I appreciate everybody working on
that because it's got to be tough okay
Timo says there are a lot of issues to
resolve before it's usable okay so it
may be a while I don't know but I'm like
that I'm sure if there are more people
that are helping out with things it
could be ready so I would you know if if
you have any time at all to to volunteer
to help with that check it out you know
check out some of the some of the issues
see if you can solve some of them and
see Rishabh says for awhile we can use
[Music]
Codecademy introduction to react yeah
I've done their intro to react I don't
know they may have updated it from when
I did it but when I did it it was it
wasn't bad it helped I hope I learned
some of the basic stuff didn't really
make me an expert but it got me through
some of the basic stuff which was nice
especially if you don't want to have to
deal with a lot of the setup to run on
your local machine it's it's good to be
able to do some in browser stuff alright
another question
Regan s can we call web developer a
software engineer I don't I don't know I
wouldn't personally
would there be some justification for
that I don't I don't really know I know
there's like heated debate about terms
of which you can call different
developers and engineers and things like
that so I'm not gonna I don't really
need to feel like I don't have enough
information to weigh in on that question
to be honest with you when it comes to
titles in this industry it seems almost
like whatever you like whatever job you
can convince somebody that you can do
like that's your title because some of
these titles are just like I just I feel
like sometimes they don't really mean
that much because it's such a broad
range of things right I mean we're in an
industry where people have titles like
JavaScript ninja right I mean or like
PHP wizard I mean you know it's like I
don't really know what makes somebody an
engineer as opposed to a programmer or a
developer if there's some resource out
there that clearly defines those terms
for our industry then you know that'd be
great but I don't know about it so I'm a
like I said I would not call myself an
engineer but I wouldn't be a poet if
somebody offered a job calling me a
front-end engineer I'll take it that
sounds like a cool title if somebody
wanted to hire me to do front-end work
but my title would be software engineer
I'll I would take it I mean I I would
think it would be weird you know but I
wouldn't be like totally opposed to it
let's see okay Timo says I'm a core team
member for the free code can't beta
curriculum so we can definitely use the
help of more active contributors Oh
awesome
cool so Timo thanks for for your
contributions and being a core team
member that's awesome and thanks for the
info no beer says no to the question of
web developers being called a software
engineer Timo says I believe in Texas a
four-year degree is required to have the
title of engineer uh-huh I had never
even considered that so I guess in some
places the title engineer is I guess
legally may be reserved to certain
degrees that's really interesting rish
up says I've been working on react Redux
in graph QL so it's always good to do
something new that's cool I'll probably
right now I'm working on react to Redux
I really do want to learn more about
graph QL so I'll be following the same
path there Mandela effect as most
engineering degrees five years I don't
really know I'm pretty sure you can do
four year engineering degrees I'm trying
to think I do know somebody that got
their engineering degree I'm just trying
to remember when they graduated I'm
pretty sure they did it in four years
but I'm not positive
I mean it's always possible that they
took a bunch of summer classes and it
should have been a five year degree and
they just did it before I don't I don't
know
okay well I'm to the end of the live
chat here and this stream has gone on
for quite a while now so I can feel my
throat starting to go too so I don't
want to completely lose my voice so now
is a great time to to wrap things up so
thanks so much everyone for for watching
and let's see looks like there's some
more questions what question come in
coming in so I'm gonna leave I'm gonna
because we seem to get a never-ending
stream of questions so if I don't get
your question if you're putting it in
right now into the live chat go ahead
and ask me - for tomorrow stream or you
can send me a send me a message on on
Twitter or some other social media and
you put in the comments to the video you
could join our slack channel for this
stream and ask everyone in there I think
the link to the slack channel is in the
description so next next stream is
probably going to be tomorrow around 2
p.m. Eastern time so same time is today
unless something comes up and then I'll
either reschedule or cancel but I'll let
everyone know on Twitter in any case
what's gonna happen yeah I think that's
it all right so again thank you everyone
and really really great chat at the end
there it went on for quite a while and a
lot of great questions and answers I
appreciate appreciate all of it all the
questions and answers and yes so have a
great day I'll see y'all tomorrow
you